[Music]
i was reflecting on this today the risk
you took
when you took on the iconic role of
spock
this is a very vocal serious community
of star trek fans and if you don't nail
it which by the way you did
they'd have torn you limb from limb were
you scared of of taking on the rule of
spock they're not fooling around these
people yeah there's no denying it maybe
some of them are here yeah
but uh they've been incredibly
supportive for the whole you know it's
like five years ago that we made that
movie and now we're getting ready to get
to uh in front of the other one the
second one so
you know i think they're all right i
think they're going along with us they
are i mean
you did a stunning job but i would have
to think just stepping into the shoes or
the boots if you will of leonard
leonard nimoy uh you know who so
create the role and defined it so much
that's got to be next to he's such a
great guy though and immediately he
embraced me and supported me so you got
to work with him i know he was in the
movie but he really helped you we've
become very very good friends actually
and he was uh always there always
available and uh you know an incredible
part of the process for me so i feel
really lucky for him yeah in my life now
even even though we're not working
together on this next one well this is
interesting because uh not too long ago
jj abrams the director of the of the
franchise came on the show and he showed
three frames don't even get me started
on this guy you know i mean i think she
what he comes here he brings so i
decided actually he showed three frames
of the new star trek movie people lost
their minds it was three frames of view
literally three frames it was over like
that but it exploded on the net people
went crazy i want to tell you something
i i have a lot of respect for you and
your audience and i wanted to bring
something for you guys today that was
more than that you know
uh
i didn't tell jj i didn't tell paramount
so we can deal you have a legal
department right yeah
trust me these days i have a legal
department
but i wanted to show everybody something
so i think so you you brought something
more than three frames long yeah i
thought that was ridiculous
this is the first time people are going
to see this it is and we're putting nine
minutes of the movie in front of the
imax version of the hobbit starting
december 14th
so i thought why wait you know i'm going
to just come out of the game you guys
want to see this this is absolutely
incredible
all right
this is i guess a clip
this is a more extended certainly longer
than three frames certainly gonna give
you an idea of what is happening in this
film and what this film what's really
driving the movie forward in terms of
the characters and their uh obstacles
amazing all right let's take a look at
this clip from the upcoming star trek
into the darkness
jim we've got to get back to the ship
there are aliens and they will explode
[Applause]
wow
it's riveting stuff just like movies
most most guests when they show a clip
they don't wander away i know
oh thank you oh wow oh funny
snuggie i'm under the impression that
i think andy's in that movie too oh
that's next time i have a small cameo
[Applause]
i don't rate a green screen
forget it forget it
forget it
forget it come on over andy
[Applause]
for
you play with your papers